CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL ON ANNOUNCEMENT
MOST PEOPLE DID NOT SEE COMING,
AT LEAST NOT TODAY.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
THE DEMANDS OF BEING HOUSE
SPEAKER HUGE IN TERMS OF
FUND-RAISING, TRAVEL, OVERALL
STRESS.
>> PAUL RYAN SAYS HE'S HAD
ENOUGH.
>> MUCH WORK REMAINS.
I LIKE TO THINK I HAVE DONE MY
PART, MY LITTLE PART IN HISTORY
TO SET US ON A BETTER COURSE.
>> A SOURCE SAYS RYAN MADE THE
FINAL DECISION WITH HIS WIFE
OVER EASTER RECESS AND THAT AS
RECENTLY AS FEBRUARY RYAN
CONSIDERED RUNNING FOR ANOTHER
TERM.
SPEAKER TOLD HIS STAFF EARLY
THIS MORNING AND RECEIVED A
STANDING OVATION FROM HIS TEAM.
RYAN TOLD HIS REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AND REPORTERS, FAMILY
WAS A KEY CONSIDERATION.
>> WHAT I REALIZES IF I'M HERE
FOR ONE MORE TERM, MY KIDS WILL
ONLY HAVE EVER KNOWN ME AS A
WEEKEND DAD.
I JUST CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN.
>> RYAN ALSO SPOKE BY PHONE THIS
MORNING WITH HIS HOUSE G.O.P.
LEADERSHIP TEAM, VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT SALUTED RYAN'S
SERVICE ON TWITTER, CALLING HIM
A TRULY GOOD MAN WHO WILL LEAVE
AN UNQUESTIONABLE LEGACY OF
ACHIEVEMENT.
AMONG THE CHALLENGES FOR RYAN, A
VOCAL BLOCK OF HOUSE
CONSERVATIVES WHO CHALLENGED HIS
LEADERSHIP.
IN NEGOTIATING PARTNER IN THE
PRESIDENT WHO AT TIMES COULD BE
UNPREDICTABLE.
THE PRESIDENT THREATENED TO VETO
A $1.320 PENDING BAGGAGE THAT HE
ONCE EMBRACED.
ANOTHER FRUSTRATION WAS
CAMPAIGNING FOR YEARS ON
REPEALING AND REPLACING
OBAMACARE AND THE SENATE COMING
UP SHORT.
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER NOTED
THAT RYAN DIDN'T ASPIRE TO BE
SPEAKER.
>> LIKE A TRUE LEADER, PAUL
STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE.
HE ANSWERED HIS COLLEAGUES' CALL
WITH THE EARNEST, SELFLESS, AND
FOCUSED APPROACHED THAT HAS
DEFINED HIS ENTIRE CAREER IN
CONGRESS.
>> TOP DEMOCRATS SANG HIS
PRAISES TOO.
>> SPEAKER RYAN IS A GOOD MAN.
HE'S ALWAYS TRUE TO HIS WORD,
EVEN THOUGH WE DISAGREED ON MOST
ISSUES, IN THE AREAS WHERE WE
COULD WORK TOGETHER, I FOUND HIM
TO BE SMART, THOUGHTFUL, AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
I FOUND HIM TO HAVE A GREAT DEAL
OF INTEGRITY.
>> MAJOR HIGHLIGHT FOR THE
POLICY WALK WAS THE FIRST TAX
REFORM IN MORE THAN 30 YEARS,
AND HIS COLLEAGUES SAY THERE IS
STILL TIME.
>> I THINK PAUL IS WHEN TO BE
ANYTHING BUT LAME DUCK.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO GET MORE THINGS DONE WHILE
HE'S HERE.
>> IN TERMS OF WHAT'S NEXT FOR